this is a production of Cornell
University all right thanks Frank
thanks for coming today this is
something that I started at at Madison
before I had my little hiatus on this
topic for my three and a half years here
and nikka working with Frank and then
researcher we've kind of picked back up
at Nebraska and it's something that's
really been pretty impactful through our
turf industry and so I'm really excited
to be able to share share with you today
at Nebraska I have a three-way split I'm
an extension specialist so 50% of my
time is extension and then I 20%
teaching load and a 3% research load
which I enjoy people usually hate
three-way splits but I really do like
doing all three aspects of the job and
for my extension side I really focus on
how to become more precise managers so
you know how are we making sure that
we're applying the right fertilizer is
the right amount of water or the right
product when it's needed and one of the
ways of doing that is to harness data
and analyze data and to make decisions
that are based on models and the latest
research so that we're not you know
getting stuck in these calendar-based
systems kind of like in turf but also I
know for my time here and a lot of our
crops like apples right we have a spray
schedule we sit down we sprayed every
week or two weeks because we can't
tolerate any type of disease or any type
of past or in a turf situation and grass
wants us to look and perform well and so
we're trying constantly trying to bat a
balance or input so that the grass is
looking good but it's not looking too
good and it's also you know free of any
kind of disease or weed or insect pests
and so I'm really gonna talk today about
how do we use that data it's gonna be
kind of a high-pitched pop kind of a
high of you and I want to tell a little
bit of a story of how I've gotten to
this point where I started off you know
their backyard putting green and and now
I'm you know the CEO of a start-up tech
company and you know it's it's quite a
learning curve over the last 10 years to
go from one to the other
so kind of my challenge is it's hurting
a turf industry I think the challenge of
people like Frank and other extension
specialists and different crops are you
know there's a lot of information out
there now social media has been huge for
me
I've really been able to grow my my
presence in the turf industry and grab
like 3,500 twitter twitter followers and
are all turf people and he just it's a
great way to get information out there
now when you have all these people
constantly putting information out there
there's a lot of information that's new
things can get buried and so that can be
kind of a challenge how do we gain
better adoption of best management
practices and got me on a horticultural
when we have you know good science any
bad science being spewed through
different social media sites that's one
of the challenges that I see right now
another challenge is we have all this
data we can collect how are we taking
that data and those data and we bring
them together so that we can make quick
decisions we we don't have time to spend
10 hours a day trying to combine all
these data and trying to analyze them
and then make a decision you almost get
paralyzed by that data and then also you
know what's the return on investment to
spending all that time or to buying the
equipment or to paying for computer
power to analyze all these data so that
we can make decisions and so great I can
I can do GPS free applications on my
golf course or on any kind of farm
am I getting a return either in plant
bility or from economic perspective or
from a time perspective and so we really
have to keep all of those things in mind
we're trying to understand what we can
do is extension specialists to try to
expand the reach of our of our
programming and we're seeing
technologies exploding too so 10 years
ago no golf courses had these soil
moisture probes and now everybody has
them and they have an app now that this
probe can't agree with and then we have
drones coming in a turf industry and
they can make pretty maps but they
really can't so really tell you what to
do with the information that's on these
different maps this is thermal imaging
there's different crop indices like NDVI
or ndre
and so we have all these different
disparate sources of information
nothing is talking to each other I got
my soil moisture map I got my my thermal
imaging map I have you know handwritten
data from how fast the putting greens
are from where the cup might be cutting
green how do I combined all that
information right
now it's all sputum screwed around it's
really hard for a superintendent or even
a sports field manager to handle all
that to them make clear decisions we
also have a lot of weather models and so
this is far from a website at Michigan
State does a nice job on your own degree
day track with that net and they take
different pest models and from this they
can understand you know some of the
phonology and some of the different
timings and life cycles of different
pests and different plants and give some
feedback but again this is not another
source of information the turf manager
has to actively seek out I think that
we're gonna continue to see these models
expand over time in our industry I think
across a lot of industries you know pest
models have historically been something
that we've been doing research on now
for 30 or 40 years I think Frankie
applies the research for the annual
bluegrass this particular challenging
weed that's permit making seed heads and
when would you spray when would you
expect to see these seed heads from
occurring we have some newer models for
really challenging diseases like dollar
spots it's a disease that can be pretty
problematic in our climate and some some
new models are predicting when that's
going to emerge you're also seeing some
newer models though away from the pest
models for things like nutrient use and
growth potential before I'm here today
we are talking in Frank's office about
golf courses now actually just keeping
track of how many clippings are good and
this seems like something that you'd
think is kind of fundamental for growing
grass we wouldn't know about how much
grass is being mowed because that's
gonna tell us how ability its ability to
kind of handle traffic how nutrients are
being removed during the clipping finger
moves how sugar is being allocated
within that plant and we're not leaving
doing that and so that's an opportunity
there and I think people are starting to
explore but I want to talk about some of
the research that I started doing as a
high school student and that's turned
into what I've been doing now and that's
looking at plant growth regulators I'm
going to use this as kind of a backdrop
for the context the story has shown how
I've kind of developed into building
this
decision support tool so Plato's
regulators are frequently applied to
highly maintained turf but they're also
extremely difficult to understand if
they're working and because of that
they're hot they're very frequently
misunderstood so most of the products
that we're using in turf inhibit
gibberellin biosynthesis biosynthesis
and that hormone crosses our leaves to
elongate so the more jibber elements
present the faster the grass is growing
I'm sure many here they have to mow
lawns probably would love to spray these
four layers on your grass because you
don't want to have to mow it as much and
so that's kind of what the the thinking
is behind some of these products so some
of the common ones that the most common
one is a particular product connects up
a couple it's a very safe plant growth
regulator very minimal negative
attributes
phyto toxicity is low and then we have
some some other PG R's Pat the future's
all and humid all those are route absorb
PG are a little bit more cytotoxic and
turf but still use pretty frequently and
so you might think well why am i putting
down something that's gonna make my
grass grow slower on a golf course
you mow a green every day you mow
fairways two or three times a week
well the real benefit to these products
come from they reduce clipping yields
which therefore reduce our nutrient
requirements and we're also mowing less
of that stored carbohydrate off so we've
seen flat health benefits we see an
improved strokes times and we also see
enhancements and inter playability
performance you see a denser stand of
turf you see an increase in green color
so I got into this research because of
this stress tolerance when I was fifteen
I had that back yard putting green I had
a lot of shade issues by trying to
suppress some of the phytochrome growth
response from growing grass in the shade
we're putting these products out onto
the turf and as a high school kid I'm
like honey I just work how do you how do
you make sense out of this so a
superintendent I worked for word kind of
explained it to me it's just kind of how
would I draw a drawn up for holidays
products worked so we have relative
clipping yield here on the y-axis so
this
how fast the grass would grow if we did
not apply a plant growth regulator and
then at day zero I put down my primo max
Whiterun x-pac ethel and we see that the
cleveland he'll start to grow slower and
slower and slower and so we see a 20
percent reduction in our clipping you
not a lot but enough to improve that
plant health and reduce it the nutrient
removal and then after about a week we
saw it kind of wear off and then all the
sugars that we'd store and all the
benefits that we gained in the
suppression phase then kind of get
burned later on in this rebound phase
you see a buildup of gibberellin
precursors and so once that PGR is gone
now all those precursors become active
forms of gibberellin and the grass grows
like crazy and it burns your
carbohydrates and all the plant health
benefits we're trying to see our loss
and so you'd think okay it's pretty
simple you know you just have to just
apply the PGR is fairly frequently to to
maintain clipping yield suppression you
want to avoid the rebound so you might
say I need to apply of every about ten
days
you could also say I just watch the
grass and when it starts to regrow maybe
I'll just reapply the PGR the problem
with that is the absolute clipping
yields are all over the board and this
is what we were talking about at Frank's
office before this thing's like
mineralization of nitrogen water status
other environmental factors cause the
absolute clipping yield to fluctuate a
lot from day to day so the black line
here is plots that are treated or not
treated with plant growth regulators and
the red lines are plots that were
treated with plant growth regulators and
so there's times where we apply the PGR
and we had less clipping yield and then
the PGR wears off and we see a little
bit of a rebound and then we reapply the
PGR we have a little more suppression
and then it wears off and it's
rebounding again but we're not
maintaining that clipping yield
suppression so we're not maintaining all
those plant health benefits
therefore we shouldn't waste our money
with these applications and if we're
like me growing grass in the shade we're
not really maximizing the health of that
turf and this is a prime example this is
a 2015 PGA Championship I was
volunteering there at Whistling Straits
going into that
that tournament they were dry they were
cool weather and then the Friday before
the tournament week started they got
three quarters of an inch of rain and
then it got really warm we see a
mineralization flush there's a big
increase in plant available water and we
see really really rapid growth during
the week of the tournament they ended up
using the models I want to talk about in
a second so we knew that PG others were
working but if they weren't apply using
those models they would say hey that PG
r doesn't work anymore his prime she
says crap you know I don't waste my
money on it so we needed some kind of a
model to help guide these applications
because her eyes aren't going to really
tell us you forgetting clipping yield
suppression or rebound therefore are we
getting these plant health benefits or
not so look at that look at the class
research this is you know before I
started my research in 2005 we found
that during the summertime we see a
reduction and efficacy of the product
specifically how long did it last so we
found that it lasted for pretty sure so
if I wanted to visualize that curve I
showed before which would be in that
blue line when it's really hot outside
I'm talking about ethica heatwave so
that the Haveri temperature would be 90
degrees so that's like a high of you
know upper 90s lows in the upper 70s you
know we're seeing like seven days of
gross suppression out of these these
products like primo max which next back
Gothel but there we go it's the kind of
weather like we're having right now or
maybe even colder than right now we
might get three three weeks gross
oppression with that same product so
this was you know something we did and
early two-thousands got published in
2009 and now how do I get this into the
hands of our superintendents right
that's a challenge to me as an extension
specialist can I make this easy and you
know talking about a sine wave curve
it's a really good way for people's eyes
to glaze over really really quickly
right so we wanted to do was try to see
if there some kind of a way that we can
predict these timings so what we did is
we applied a growing degree to a base
approach to trying to see if we could
understand this the skew and the period
of the sine wave based on growing degree
to accumulation and get it
from thinking about things in calendar
days since research was started in 2008
it's pretty boring it's pretty simple I
think it's kind of novel way of thinking
about something but actually doing it's
not very hard you go out you spray your
plant growth regulators and then you
just collect clippings over and over and
over every day for ten years or not look
to what 70,000 clippings have been
collected from this research you have
different PG ARS different rates
different grass areas it's a lot and
then all you do is we just fit the
relative clipping yield to the growing
degree dead data and then from that we
can estimate what our application
intervals are so our first study was
done with this tradition pack Athlon
Bank cross cutting greens and when we we
follow only applied as the label said
every four weeks that we'd apply the PGR
and then we have suppression and then it
wear off and we get that rebound so very
counterintuitive counterproductive not
helping help them our plant out weed
reapply suppression rebound suppression
and then the starting to occur on that
through applications obviously not what
we want to do but we took all this data
instead of plotting it as Cal today on
the bottom we did it as cumulative
growing degree days after application so
this is application at day zero and then
growing degree days which is just a
summation of the average air temperature
in degrees Celsius we use for the base
of 0 degrees Celsius using graphs we
test a different basis and the base zero
had the greatest through R squared value
so that's why we had confidence in that
but we found that for about 0 to 200
growing degree days after application we
had suppression and then from about
three to eight hundred nine degrees we
had a rebound and so if we based on a
research done else they would apply it
230 or fewer growing degree days be able
to maintain their creeping yield
suppression so this could be if the
average temperature is 20 degrees that's
10 days if the average temperature is 10
degrees you've got 22 intervals right so
now it's being flexible so we're
applying these herbicides and these
plant protection products based on the
metabolism of the product and not just
based on what the label says for a
counter so what we still only applied PG
ours every 200 growing degree
we had a nice even clipping the old
suppression averaging about fifteen
percent less than the control and it no
was at or below the control for the
entire growing season as a result we saw
an improvement in the color and the
quality and it danced to you that plant
you see an improvement and things like
shade tolerance and heat tolerance and
we throw know that application rate
didn't really affect interval very much
I only talked about that today for lack
of time but if you've got higher rates
instead of having fifteen percent
average depression you might get thirty
percent so we've been doing this tile
for ten years how's the first study
we've been doing it for all these
different plant growth regulators and
this is just the table for one putting
green so this is creeping bentgrass
putting green the rate range so but the
rate effect would have on the amount of
suppression what the ideal intervals it
being growing degree days for all the
different products and then a
superintendent start mixing products on
me and they start asking but what if I
mix this product with that product
you know how much suppression do I get
how long does it last right and so these
are really challenging questions I go I
don't know I get to figure it out
yourself I guess so again I'm taking all
this data and I can get a publishing
it's great that's not the last step the
last step is getting it into the hands
of our end users so they can actually
use it and make decisions and how
they're applying their products so it
was a non computer person but a data
person as most you guys are you go to
Excel so you build Excel sheets like
this and I was pretty proud of this
there's a lot of if-then statements in
there and looking up a files and color
code based on things so the
superintendent would come in pick their
temperature unit their active ingredient
the rate they wanted to use then our
models were kicking on the backside tell
them what their ideal growing the
greeting interval should be if they
wanted to make their own they could even
set their own interval and then I would
come in and they could pick is if the
days they applied the plant growth
regulators and it would tell them what
their cumulative growing degree days
were and their approximate levels of
clipping the old suppression and then
they would warn them when they need to
reapply I even knew some extra if things
in there so you can
in the forecasted weather and so you
could say well maybe I have to reapply
on this state even though it's currently
you know a week away it works pretty
well it worked really well for bang
crash screams but there were some
challenges there another question
someone asked was well this is great I'm
really bad at sprayer math so can you
help me out with a sprayer math so you
go to another sheet and you you haven't
put in this the area that they want to
spray and you know the sprayer setup how
many gallons of water are they gonna put
over an acre and then what products so
they want to use and so you start
building all this into Excel and you put
it out there on your website and people
start downloading it but there's some
problems with that the first one is new
versions so every time I get a new model
data and I need to add something to it I
can't just easily go off to everybody
and say hey here's the new version of
the website of the app you got to stop
using the old one and use the new one
right so that was always an issue but
other problem was bugs and more
typically user problems you could
imagine if you had a cell that's got
like five if-then statements in there
and someone clicks the wrong cell and
then they send it to you and say can you
fix this for me
it's a little frustrating their problem
to is they had to manually enter their
weather data over and over and over so
this was some of the kind of the
functional problems with an Excel type
of an approach to to using these
different types of models I know
Cornell's got some great models their
Excel base for things like soil test
interpretations and mineralization and
they're really good but they can be a
little bit intimidating even for me I
thought they no should know what's going
on I still looking at no like okay how
do I do this you know the right way
from a bigger picture perspective though
it's an Extension educator I'm
constantly asked about you know how do
you document this kind of stuff how do
you document your impact instead of just
saying like well it was downloaded 400
times well big deal are four people
actually using it are they actually
implementing the recommendations based
on this so they just download it once
and then you know threw it out because
they didn't know how to use it and so
that's another problem that we have an
extension as it is how do we document
what we're doing if we write a
publication about how we should do
something but then we don't really and
they can come no how many times it's
downloaded we still don't know how
people actually doing it are we getting
a change in practice and so we needed
some ways more interactive this is very
one-sided
I give them information it goes out to
them they choose to use it or not I want
something that I give out to them they
can use within this they're using it
it's coming back to me so that I can
understand you know how are they using
these products I'll be implementing it
what are some ways I could evolve my
research committees to meet some of the
challenges that they're giving me so I
need I need some more communication
through my extension so it was it became
pretty clear to me and this actually
came to me it clear to me at Cornell one
of my good friends in small was Plant
Pathology PhD student work and decision
support tool and Bill Fry's lab and I
was like I got this idea for one for
Turk to when I freeze plant growth
regulators and he's like I'll ask cool
bill and so I left Cornell and I you
know no I'm a professor and I have a
startup package and I'm like I want to
put some money into trying to build on
that which is really intimidating right
because none of us have background in
really software design and it's a whole
language and something we're just not
really comfortable with it took some
time it took about two years so the
first thing you're thinking about is you
got to find developers that you can
actually do this and in Lincoln we're
having this surge of they call it the
silicon Prairie now all these companies
are coming from Silicon Valley to cheat
Nebraska there's a wealth of student
new graduates and so it's hard to find
even developers and you get what you pay
for you can pay a lot of money like 200
grand to build a map but it might be
awesome but if you missed the market
anything but other thing I'll redevelop
it and it's gonna be 200 more thousand
dollars to get it there or you do what I
do and you hire some cheaper small firm
they take forever and they're not
responsive so it took a couple years to
kind of get things going
funding support was important so one of
the things I did is I went to my
department head and said iris idea
can you help you know help me with that
initial startup cost you try making
money on it I'll pay you back if we
don't make money on it then I guess
you're out so you know not a lot of risk
for him but he still said it's a good
enough idea we're going to do it design
considerations this is huge I'm building
an app it's got to be intuitive people
on your phone right now I'm sure you're
realizing if the app is not intuitive
and easy you're not gonna use it right
and only you know how a grower is going
to use this type of technology because
you've probably done it you work with
them in the field you know what they
want to see you know what they don't
want to see an app guide my first
attempt at this they did it themselves
it was hideous and ugly and not
functional so now I have to come in
every time we do variants I draw up in
PowerPoint this is what I want to do
this is how it has to work it takes time
but you save time and money later on
because you're not redoing is there
their initial tab which usually is
nowhere near what and use yours and then
you spend all this money you're on the
hook and now you have to figure out how
am I going to advertise it home and get
adoption the benefit there is having
that big Twitter following if you build
something that works you get this good
word of mouth especially in the
tight-knit community like the turf
industry and so we've seen a really nice
adoption of it this is not greenkeeper
this is what I did for my my interview
though at Nebraska so I came in right
away and said this is what I want to
build when I get here and so I drew this
up right before my interview you know it
had things like my record keeper and
right like the weather forecast and pest
outbreak maps and online resource
that link to our information it was
gonna display things like what products
were applied so I can keep tracking my
PG arse if I'm tracking my PJs I can
also track fungicides I can track
fertilizers I can track water right so
that just kind of became intuitive and
if I know someone's true spraying on
fungicide for example now I can start
seeing where they are and start building
Maps as I understand oh maybe we have a
lot of dollar spot outbreak in southeast
Nebraska well their users could then
gain and learn from that so instead of
having to pick up the phone and say hey
what are you seeing your course right
now they can just go onto the app and
they can see what's kind of going on in
their region so over time we've ended up
building our app called greenkeeper and
so this is a decision support tool it's
got a terrible name it's green keeper
app it's not really an app you download
it's a web-based apps but it really
confuses people so if you're ever gonna
build an app make sure it's really a
native app for your phone or just call
it green keeper which is the way I try
to refer to it now unfortunately that
domain was unavailable so keep your app
is where it's at right now and so you
can access it through internet browser
one nice thing about this is think about
your growers they are gonna be in the
field they're gonna want to sit on the
phone they might see on a tablet they
might do a lot of data entry on their
computer so by doing a web-based app now
they have a lot more flexibility in in
how they can interact with that and they
can see in access or data any any other
location they said what it really looks
like it is not pretty in the app side we
call this front end front end makes
things look beautiful my guys love doing
the backend stuff figuring out the
algorithms figuring out the code they
hate Fernet so that's the thing I could
hire someone to make it look pretty
but we're finding from our
superintendents is they love it because
it's ugly but it's simple and it's easy
so they can log in they can see what's
been applied to their greens they can
watch the products expire they can see
how they've been fertilizing if you
scroll down they click at the weather
but get reminders when things you know
come out of control and so it's it's
real simple website
if you're looking okay we're do any
website analytics to see how many people
are using your site one thing people
want is a low number it's called their
bounce rate a bounce rate means you go
onto the website and then you want
someone to stick there and click around
they don't want to like log on to your
site and say this I don't need anything
here in this leap but for me I want a
decent bounce rate because I want my
superintendents to log in every day look
at the homepage and go I'm pretty good
today I can go on and do something else
right so that's actually a good thing to
have sometimes you said to know what the
goal so our PGR display is real easy now
that the a query keeps track of five
hundred and seventy variants of those
grown ingredients so they don't have to
know all of the the ins and outs of the
model I had automatic grabs or other
data every night I have to pay for that
used to be six hundred dollars a month
we switches over to a different provider
that's fifty bucks a month but you know
it's automatically in the weather data
and the ten-day forecast
so for these PG hours for example this
one trim it Popovich's all what I was
praying for was PGR a day I sprayed the
day it's likely to expire based on the
forecast in this case it really has
expired
the amount of growing degree days that
we're at versus what we are goal
reapplication interval was and then how
much Depression a rebound that we get so
this treatment is starting to go from
suppression into rebound
whereas this primo max on the t's is
still not yet expired and it's going to
expire you know several weeks later so
real quick superintendent looks at it
and go oh I'm gonna spray next Monday
I'll throw the Primo on the tank then
they go on with their day it's quick
it's easy and all the data is in the
background we've also been expanded it
to do things like the sprayer mixing we
know they struggle with math so they is
coming down when they pick I'm treating
my greens this is the sprayer it tells
them how many tanks how many gallons and
then they come in they picked the
products they want to use the raids the
pass the interval they'd like to use if
it's not based on growing degree days
and it gives them a nice list of how
much product is needed to makes a full
tank to make partial thanks it keeps
track of all this inventory so it's real
simple for a superintendent
and you know have that and they push
finalized mix they get a PDF they can
print off they give it off to a spray
tech you're an intern and they mix it up
and it's less chance for a math there so
right there we could have a big impact
but trying to minimize some of those
math days he always comes on to me
though for that math to be right right
so you have to do a lot of we call it QA
Quality Assurance and make sure that you
know you do different models so your
make sure your math is working a way
that needs to work so it's recording the
big features of greenkeeper initially
and so over the last two years we've
gone from zero to thirty eight hundred
courses fifty nine hundred users
multiple users can be shared at one
course and we've tracked eighty-nine
thousand different products so what I'm
talking about extension impacts now
that's my impact I can show who's using
it how's how it's being used how offer
they logging in but more importantly
right here products being tracked I can
see how are they using this PGR aaanthor
ways how they using this BGR and greens
what rates are they using what intervals
- they like all the sudden now I can
document my impact to my extension bean
is show that my research is being
applied directly to growers and they're
using it and that's something you get
when you develop an app like this so you
know Google Analytics is great so right
now you know we're doing about one point
seven thousand logins a month from our
different users and so we have a bunch
of users that try it out but these are
kind of our monthly active users one
point seven hundred one thousand seven
areas which is really really great
amount of adoption for through the app
our users are highly engaged which is
great they give us amazing testimonials
like Bill keen here you know with
greenkeeper I've made five fewer PGR
apps for my greens and two fewer to my
fairways that's real savings and product
later another way you can rate document
your impact if you're an extension
specialist the other problem trade-off
there they give you a lot of feedback
they feel invested in this so they're
going to tell you what they
what they like what they don't like
that's all kind of being added and it's
great because then you do what they want
it's other buddies about how they you
know and they had the idea for this and
we did this and it's continuing to make
this decision support you will grow so
if you're thinking about developing a
tool like this the the most important
thing to remember to make it successful
is that you need to offer your end-users
more value and time and money than they
put into an application there's a lot of
apps out there they want you to answer
all this information you know everything
but they don't really give anything back
this app is giving you so much
information back with past models and
fertilizer tracking fertilizer
recommendations these PG are models that
could be complex people to calculate
it's all right there and it's
automatically updating for them
and so that it's worth their time so you
can give you all their sprayer
information to assess your room so you
know like this the new dollar spot model
again make it real simple so that we
have all their areas there they put a
stress disease threshold their wrist
rest rolled so they can look at some
really complex model it automatically
tells them not the number just are they
protected or at risk real simple real
quick
it can it consults with the yet what
fungicides have been spray if a
fungicide had been sprayed on these back
nineties and this namely your threshold
was above 20% it would just say
protective because you're still
protected if the growers I need to know
oh that fungicide protects against this
disease it's automatically my penalty
another like pet peeve of mine is soils
and we've all you know we do modeling
and the front understand with the soil
phosphorus potassium levels are
maintaining our turf but then you look
at soil test reports from labs and
they're gonna analyze everything all
your molybdenum is know whoa what are
you talking about you molybdenum is low
like it's crazy there's no research to
support that that number so then we said
okay well we can do soil testing we can
you tissue testing in here you just pick
where your samples from and knows about
your site you give a little barcode you
send it off to lab two days later we get
the important thing oil pH
for pH Organa matter may looks three may
look phosphorus potassium the things
actually important and then we give
University recommendations so if you're
doing like a salt test on sand and you
sink your sodium is high it just says
interpretations is not applicable you're
on sand you don't have the population of
clay right other globs would try to
scare you and tell you you got Polly's
products down now we can just pump the
universal recommendations right into a
tool and we can do it cheap we do like
twenty bucks for a sample independent
soils consultants can charge you $100
for a sample and so we can just kind of
cut some of that right out of the system
there have been some growing pains we've
been growing a lot and the university
knows is that bill this is awesome eat a
former LLC like cool you know I had the
support and the protection of the big
University behind you
he knew this pretty low risk who has
ever done a SWOT analysis you know
strengths weaknesses opportunities
threats universities come on we don't
have SWOT analysis we don't when you're
you have protection behind you if you're
a private industry you better know those
you know your weaknesses and your
threats really clearly so a little bit
scared about that they said first of all
you're making money and universities
nonprofit so that's a problem you're
putting credit cards state law in
Nebraska says we cannot store credit
card information so that was a problem
and then you have all the university
constraints about user agreements and
how do you use the logo and all this
stuff it just got crazy so we had to
form an LLC another Cornell alumni my
master's advisor
I've sold out and I formed our turf
great LLC and now we pay a small royalty
revenue to Nebraska the other problem
comes up in is now we have all these
ideas how do we fund it right it's a
free app people want stuff for free
online like for some reason people think
they don't have to pay for stuff online
so there's different there's different
models out there for us to kind of make
this work
but you know looking for partnerships
looking at ways they can roll the
greenkeeper app and so develop rapidly
because there's other apps out there and
if we're not developing then we're going
to have some problems
and then you know just the challenges of
trying to run a small growing startup on
top of having a three-way appointment as
a professor so these are some of the
challenges that I've been trying to face
they're very supportive of this because
they are getting some royalty money out
of it
but it's just some of the issues that
I'm having so if you're thinking about
developing an app and successful these
are some real things that come along a
couple years later that are gonna be
kind of smack you in the face and you
have to be kind of aware of as I kind of
wrap up though I wanted to show you know
where is the app going it's much it's
give me a much broader than the things
I've showed today and you know I'm not
doing much PGI research we've done a lot
of it but we're not we're doing you're
getting into GPS freyr's variable rate
sensors you know the big thing in egg
crops the sensors on mowers and drones
but we don't need that in turf why we
take a drone over our grass every day
every three days right and it's got a
active sensor connected to a battery so
we can have really nice crop matter crop
monitoring cops coding technology it's
just sitting on the back of a mower and
so from that we can look at water status
and disease and a nitrogen status and
and so this is some of the data that
we've been collecting this is just a
different fairway over time as you can
see the stress starts picking up in the
summer time so we're able to start
looking at that and modeling that and so
all the research that we're doing now is
getting pumped right back into our
greenkeepers so we're trying to balance
you know our research to make sure we're
sitting the needs that you need for
precision turf management and so this
this is one one of them things I think
we're really excited about going forward
if you don't want to use a sensor on a
more you can all use it on a Segway so
this is one of our GIS guys who you know
is also a pilot but he's got us is a
pollen scientific ACS for 30 crop sensor
on there and he's just driving a putting
green and from that you know he can get
up it can learn a lot about you know how
that puting green grass is performing
nitrogen is performing
and then ultimately we hope I want
greenkeeper to look something like this
so this is kind of a Google Earth
overlay of the different fairways here
at this gym acre golf course is a golf
course that I kind of took over from the
city our students now I'll take care of
this is awesome your students are taking
care of it they're getting real-world
experience and then I can use as a
research test facility and so now we're
looking at you know mating GPS failure
rate end applications to try to even out
some of these differences in the
chlorophyll content of these leaves and
so I think it's a pretty cool
opportunity to have that in Lincoln so
I'm not gonna go long because Katie and
I both remember sitting and seminars I
just go way over so I'm gonna wrap up
here because I know you guys probably
want to go to how was your day if you're
thinking about decision support tool is
an extension I think it's a great way to
engage your growers and to expand your
audience and it's really interactive
they're getting it two-sided you're not
just you know providing information and
just hoping and praying that they're
actually using what you're telling them
I think it's a lot opportunities out
there this is church but a lot of
especially our highly maintained
specialty crops and we see a lot of
applications being applied a lot of data
could be being collected you know I
think there's aa plication Xin there
apples grapes green house my wife is
doing hop stuff now in Nebraska and just
keeping track of all that you know downy
mildew pressure applications fertility
drip lines et a lot of data you could
build these types interfaces for lots of
different crops out there it's a great
way for our for us to integrate our
science in a way that's intuitive and
helpful to our growers and something
that they want to engage and that's how
you can go from zero users to you know
3800 golf courses in two years
perspective there's about 12,500 preen
nicely maintained golf courses in the
United States so for us I have about a
quarter of those you know maintain the
golf courses it kind of picks up for the
3,000 mom-and-pop so you know I barely
solvent I think it's a pretty massive
amount of integration and it's just by
using the our data and putting it away
this intuitive and helpful and ease
so thank you very much for having me
today I'd be happy to take any questions
now hi Bill Jennifer grant I hate your
questions for you you talked about you
know keeping the competitive edge and
that there's a lot of competition out
there could you comment on what you see
as competition in the turf industry
right now are these for this type of
information and applications and
secondly on what I wondered if you have
many or any non golf course users yeah
the first other edge of the second
question first
that's we have sports turf people are
using it we actually have athletic
fields built in as an area type of thing
greenkeeper so when the grown degree do
miles for sports turf is also in
greenkeeper I guess from a competition
perspective there's different apps out
there there's a bunch like on Lincoln
and playbooks and a lot of them are
keeping track of apps but it's different
from us versus them and we're giving
them the users information back we're
having those models in there and some of
us 570 models I haven't published
because I haven't been proprietary so
you know they just can't put it into
their apps and so that's an issue I
think the biggest threat right now for
us there's a lot of apps there's a lot
of like growing technologies or sensor
technologies for soil moisture meters
and we're seeing partnerships happen
really rapidly and so I think that's
going to be the one thing we look at is
you know making constantly assessing how
those parts is performing and looking at
it from a business perspective now that
it's LLC not just university I
so your screen up there says protected
from dollar spot so what happens when
the Golf Course does get so that if you
go back to that they they can actually
pick their threshold and so what you'd
say then is okay maybe you have a weaker
cultivar of grass and so you have to go
to low-earth action thresholds and so
that's the way we kind of make that
happen and also to when they put in
their interval for how long those
fungicides last they know it's really
high pressure don't put a 28-day
interval if you know it's long in the
last 14 days my counterpart at Wisconsin
to is trying to take some of this
growing degree day type environmental
degradation modeling and research and
applying it to fungicides and other
types of control products soo so we can
try to put this together with other
products the bigger challenge there is P
guys are easy and the PG air is gone it
starts to where it starts to respond the
fungicide is gone from the plant tissue
it still may be having an impact on the
pest and so there's give me a lot more
dynamic there when you're dealing with
the plant residual and the pest response
to that that critical dose of that
pesticide so it's a little bit more
challenging than the PGR which is a
pretty easy way into is there any way to
track from these users she I was able to
reduce my pesticide herbicide by just
like whatever use over time yeah that's
one thing we don't have yet and we
talked about is you know we can pool
data and they can look at how they're
number either active ingredient has been
reduced or they're aiq or whatever
metric that you want to use to assess
the risk and then we can rate how is my
number changes over time but i'm more
importantly may be more helpful is how
are you doing relative to your peers in
your area and so now if you're looking
like well i'm really high and i'm really
expensive and they're really low what
are they doing differently how can I
change my management so I think that
that would be you know one way
working on that right now with some of
the the new organism from from a price
in a use perspective and your first
question was the evaluation is not
built-in yet we're just roaming through
like Survey monkeys and and we're
getting a lot of feedback through
looking at how the products are being
used in different regions too so we
don't even have to use their bias
results we can look at their actual
product to use and so they can say
they're good but I see you know they're
low lumo use at this golf course may be
a very different than that golf course
and so sometimes it can be some bias and
how to answer those surveys they're both
so do you think universities we should
have our own extension isn't writing dis
articles anymore right it's doing
podcasts like Frank does I do videos now
where's building apps and we need the
infrastructure at universities to
produce a diversity of media and I don't
think we have it I keep pushing my
department head to say we need a podcast
booth where I can go in with good
microphones and it's soundproof it's not
me in an equity office with the fan
blowing on from the air-conditioner vent
so I think that that's definitely
something that would make a lot of sense
I tried to go and turn off the app and
this is kind of dysfunction within there
that world I had to go external and pay
someone else
to do it so I think having those
resources would make extension a lot
better then finding ways to fund
ourselves right we're not going to get a
lot of federal funding anymore or state
funding so doing things like this your
money milk is going directly back into
my program support extension in the
support research and so finding revenue
models I think one of the challenges
though is you know that's where
university is telling us to do I did
that I'd like you be the poster child of
it and what I do
how many start an LLC so you know Leslie
finances me it helps me out as a company
owner and the university is some royalty
back but they need to have some better
way of figuring out how to raise money
in extension so we can build these tools
and it's not just charge for downloads
of a you know some kind of a net guide
or some kind of a pamphlet and I think
these tools are a really some way where
we can actually make a lot of money
selling decision support tools and
taking our brains and helping our
growers you know make the right
decisions this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at Cornell
edu